[Music]
[Applause]
he's the
hall of fame head coach nfl and fox
analyst jimmy johnson back on the
program morning jimmy how are you
dan how are you doing i hadn't talked to
you in a while
what time did you get up today oh
actually 4 30. i get about 4 30 every
morning
did you get up that early when you
coached yep
about 4 35 o'clock i was in the office
by 5 30 almost
every morning what can you accomplish i
guess there's nobody there
where you know you that probably helps
yeah it's interesting you know i always
like to go in the office for a couple
hours
prior to my staff meeting to kind of go
over the
what i wanted to go you know talk about
the staff meeting what we had to
accomplish that day et cetera
and then i hired norv turner uh my
second year in dallas and so you know i
go in about 5 30 and norv's already
there
you know i didn't like that at all i
didn't like somebody
and it disrupted my whole day
and so the next morning i go in about 5
15. norv's there
and and and then about you know i tried
about 4 45 and north was there
i said hey yeah we're going to have to
stop this now we're not going to get any
sleep at all let's
let's make a pact let's go come in at
the same time at least
chuck noll famously told his assistants
to go home
like you have families go home you know
dick vermeel would
you know sleep over at the office when
he was coaching like
has coaching changed or is it still that
you're going to be here until 11 or 12
at night
it just really depends on the situation
for instance i was in charge
of personnel and and so and i talked to
urban meyer about
this uh before he took the jacksonville
job i said
you know if you're going to really use
your expertise you're going to have to
be in charge of personnel
and so that's going to be a 12 month out
of the year job
it's around the clock job if you're
doing coaching and
personnel uh now and so
that's the way it was for me now the one
thing that i did do even though i went
in the office
really early every morning i would
purposely
you know go home about 10 o'clock at
night
because i know as long as i was staying
there
my assistants were going to stay there
and i didn't want to stay there doing
busy work
just because the head coach was still in
the office so i'm i made a point to
leave the office by 10 o'clock at night
did you try to talk urban meyer out of
the jacksonville job
no actually we had a couple of
conversations uh when texas was trying
to hire him
and i i wanted to compare uh
college coaching and professional
coaching which he had never done
and i told him i said if you think
college coaching is a grind
i said hey professional coaching is a
completely different world
yeah in college you know you've even
though you've got recruiting you've got
a
family life you've got social life you
can actually go play golf in the off
season
you know you've got time to yourself i
said if you're going to be in charge of
personnel which you should be
because he knows all the college players
i said if you're going to be in charge
of personnel
as well as the head coach you're not
going to have
any time for family for social for
anything
yeah and there are coaches that could
delegate and you know they made a point
of going home like you say
you know dick for meal or some of the
rest of them but that wasn't my
personality
if there was work to be done i was going
to be there how close do you think it
was for urban to take that texas john
he debated uh on it obviously on
university of texas
is a you know it's a premier job
but i told him i said you know i had a
chance to go to texas myself leaving the
university of miami
uh i said but you know i love living in
miami
and uh so i didn't do it and
and he said you know he had already
accomplished so much
in college football in ohio state and in
florida
yeah i don't i i don't think the lure of
texas
uh meant as much to him as what it might
have been to somebody else
you famously came up with the draft
chart where you know the the you
assessed a value of where you were
picking in the draft or what draft picks
were worth
does that still hold up now and if so
let's look at desean watson
and what would you want in return if
you're the texans gm
well the one thing about the draft chart
and i've talked to a bunch of people
about this
you really can't put a player into the
draft chart
because you don't know the value of the
player the draft chart is really for
picks
versus picks okay if you're in the first
round
you want to move up you trade a third
rounder and swap number ones et cetera
et cetera
so you it put a value on all of the
picks
but al davis and i talked about this you
know
he wanted to do it you know with players
i said al you can't do it with players
you don't know the value of a player
and he said you know the thing about it
and after i did the chart i studied all
the other teams
and i studied all of their trades and he
was all over the map
as far as the value of picks and i asked
him i said you know
some teams like the 49ers they were
right along the line
and i talked to them about it they
didn't have a chart but they studied it
and so they had a little bit of an idea
and al was just
everywhere and he said you know i'm a
i'm a personnel guy i'm not a value guy
he said if i want a player i don't care
how much it takes
i'm going to go get that player and so
i'll overpay for players
uh he said you won't you know you're a
value guy
and if they're asking too much you'll
move on to the next player
but anyway with the chart you only use
it for picks
what would you give up or what would you
want for deshaun watson
uh if i was head coach david culley
uh i would go and knock on watson's door
and i'd have me a couple of michelob
ultras
and i'd say listen let's work this thing
out
somehow some way i mean i had i had a
similar situation you know
when i was in dallas you know troy
aikman didn't like me a whole lot that
first year because i drafted steve walsh
but i i drafted steve so i could trade
him later and get some picks which i got
a one two and a three for him
and i had to walk a tight rope between
the two players because i didn't want to
diminish the value of walsh and so i
couldn't play favoritism
you know with either one of them so troy
didn't like that at all
well after i traded steve i went and
knocked on troy's door
and we sat down and and we got to work
and i actually set up a tropical fish
tank for him
uh so if i'm cully i'd do whatever it
takes
you know hey forget about pride forget
about ego you go and sit with watson
and somehow work it out hey we can make
this thing work right here
with the texans we had troy on last week
and troy told us this story again about
that
nfc title game where he got concussed he
was in the hospital he said i i still
don't remember the game
but he played in the super bowl week
later jimmy
and and did not play as well as troy can
play
uh we struggled i think he might have
thrown an interception in the first half
you know
we struggled the first half and and we
went into the locker room at halftime
i i think we may have been down or you
know it was a tight game
and i told the guys i grabbed the
offensive line and emmitt
i said we're going to go back out there
and i said emmitt you get ready
that's it yeah i'm not going to give you
a breather
you know we're going to pound them we're
going to run the football we went out
there and run the power
emma touched the ball you know like
every play except one in that particular
drive and we took the lead
uh troy was not at his best because of
the concussion
so you realize that and that's where you
said to the offensive line and emmett
we're going to win this we got to win it
this way
we can't rely on troy and you know we
were
number one in the league in defense too
so you know that had a lot to do with it
uh but we ran the power you know we
pulled big old nate newton and
leading it right up on the right side we
ran the power four or five times and
took it right down the field
and scored and uh and you know and troy
in the last game of the year he didn't
play i think the last game of the year
bernie kozar came in there and helped us
you know help us beat san francisco and
so
yeah troy was not at his best you know
because of that concussion
how would you coach differently or would
you coach differently if you were
coaching now in the nfl
the league would make me coach
differently i mean we were in pads and
we were scrimmaging
uh wednesday thursday and friday you
know we never went in shorts you know we
never went
in shells we were in pads uh so the
league would make me
you know change the way i coached uh and
that's a difficult thing you know
because
if we were in in shorts in a practice i
was bored
i wanted to i wanted a physical football
team
so i i would have us in a physical
type of workout as much as it's allowed
uh and so that would be the big thing as
far as
trying to be a little bit more physical
that's why you see such poor tackling
now in in the game because they don't
tackle in practice
they don't have contact in practice and
i've talked to a bunch of trainers
around the league we did a little bit of
a study uh getting ready for the fox
show
and half a dozen of the trainers said
because there's not
contact in practices he says that really
leads to more injuries
because players don't know how to fall
players uh
are not expecting contact players don't
protect themselves
and and really the more contact you have
in their opinion uh the fewer injuries
you're going to have
especially the early i know i talked to
the trainer uh
in jacksonville and you know he had uh
tom mizelinski he played for me
in dallas and he said it takes a couple
of weeks of
contact with players uh before they get
accustomed you know to the game speed
and so not having contact in practice i
think it really hurts the team but
don't tell these players that because
these players are going to say hey you
know let's
legislate rules to where we won't have
any contact
is the greatest quarterback of all time
should it come down to the number of
super bowls you win
yeah tom brady is the greatest
quarterback of all time
but if i said you had to face a
quarterback
or let's say you had to start a
franchise there's no question
you're starting your franchise with tom
brady over no no no
no no no okay there's no question who i
started with
the greatest quarterback of all time is
tom brady because of his record in
his super bowl wins the most talented
quarterback i've ever seen
is patrick mahomes you know patrick
mahomes is unbelievable what he can
do i mean he's he can do it all he can
make all the throws you know
he has such a feel for the game he has
such vision
and he's mobile so yeah
you know patrick mahomes is the most
talented quarterback i've seen
but the greatest quarterback of all time
tom brady because of what he
accomplished
but if you said you had to face a
quarterback game on the line
the quarterback you don't want to face
in a one-game elimination is who
ultimately holmes but but but let me
cushion that a little bit
okay i would take either i would face
either quarterback
depending on their supporting cast
whichever one has the
both of them can beat you both of them
can win
but who has the best supporting cast who
has the best defense you know
we talked about our dallas teams
everybody talked about the triplets
and the triplets were the first to go in
the hall of fame but they overlooked
that we were number one in the nfl
total defense yeah now eventually
charles haley went into the
hall of fame but it's a team game dan
and
and as great as those quarterbacks are
you know
you know i talked to troy uh our second
year
he had hurt his shoulder we would have
made the playoffs he didn't make the pro
bowl
and i said i'm sorry troy i tried to get
you in the pro bowl you know
he said coach just keep supporting me
you know bringing
you know my supporting cats just keep
bringing me players
i'll go to plenty of pro bowls i thought
you were going to say montana or
or elway did they win as many super
bowls as brady
no no like starting a franchise oh no i
said patrick mahomes
i know but i thought you might have gone
elway or montana
to start a franchise over patrick
mahomes i think patrick mahomes more
talented than
either one of those two uh like i said
he's the most talented quarterback i've
ever seen
yeah i don't know if he's more talented
than l there's my opinion i think elway
you know is as maybe the most talented
quarterback i've ever seen
um and that goes back to the late late
60s
but how are we going to solve this thing
we're not
over some mick ultras tell me tell me
what you're doing with
mick ultra with the super bowl well you
know
michael ultra's got a really cool
commercial super bowl
it's you know are you happy because you
win
or do you win because you're happy and
it brought up a point to me i said you
know i'm a much better coach
you know when i'm upbeat and positive
and happy well i did a much better job
there and
it's always really a cool commercial and
plus you know just
95 calories and 2.6 carbs
and it keeps me slim and trimmed
[Laughter]
uh if it made my hair look like yours
then i i would uh definitely drink it
definitely drink it but you've got
serenas in it uh
al uh peyton manning's in the commercial
are they
they involved in this uh i've got to
recollect the cruel people
that covers it i'm not in it though
yeah why aren't you in it and well let's
let's talk
about that i need to be in it uh it's
always great to talk to you hope you're
in good health
uh good spirits and uh thanks for
joining us as always jimmy
well when you're happy you win then
thank you buddy
that's uh jimmy johnson nfl and fox
analyst two-time super bowl champ and
hall of famer